la mia credenza imbarazzante mela sono
creato da sola dopo aver visto un
episodio esplorando il corpo umano o
sulla gravidanza e la nascita
mi ero convinta che il bambino nascesse
dallo spazio pratichetti se le tette ce
le hai niente non come avere figli
infatti molti uomini a volte diciamo un
pochino sovrappeso possono fornire
secondo questa teoria maurizio costanzo
voleva un figlio da maria de filippi
male non mi ha dato solo che a lui
nasceva dallo spazio tra il mento
ciao ragazzi bentornati a una puntata di
vita buttata il tema della puntata di
oggi è da piccolo credevo che è per un
tema così importante ho pensato di
invitare all'interno degli studios di
casa mia una ragazza che come me si è
persa in quella brutta parentesi che
diciamo divide estere età buongiorno
caffè un like per gesù sto parlando di
silvia dei trentenni che mi ha chiamato
ragazza va benissimo un anomalo vecchio
relazione ragazza perché se noi perché
siamo compiuti imprese con di schede
estere cosa ha detto e schede e schede è
più slang scary però scusami scusate le
tresche re si scusa perché spedite nei
pericolosi sempre
scusate voi usate schede nella vita
no però lo usano in questo modo non è le
schede è vero perché è vero quindi esker
e quasi quasi preferisco un like per
gesù iniziamo a sentire poi vediamo che
cosa esce è da lì che la mia ispirazione
ciao vuoi niente mi madre da piccola
dopo aver visto tre story mi faceva
credere che pupazzi la notte facevano i
cestini e il ritrovato la mattina dopo
spostati non era lei che si svegliò la
notte per spostarli io non avrei dormito
no questo è bene a me mia madre una
volta mi aveva detto tipo che esistono
davvero dai nani che tipo sai quando non
trovi una cosa poi ti giri e di cima
cavoli e sono i piccoli nani che vengono
salvati fanno gli scherzi perché non lo
dire metto figlio anche da bambino
credevo che i cani si accoppiasse con i
capi quindi i cani fossero degli uomini
invece i gatti fossero delle donne e
scoprire che in realtà era tutt'altro
non è stato facile nel tardo male male
poi la sfida e poi taceva o un gatto e
un cane o occhi di gatto che usate non
posso farne a meno di citare sempre che
sono cosi
se state guardando questo video e non
conoscete occhi di gatto potete
chiuderlo
anzi no scrivete come vuoi saper
scrivere se non con i ricatti sei troppo
link non molla ai gatti cani un asino
allergica l'offeso tra l'altro un
antistaminico stamattina non sapeva
violenza perché suo padre le ha detto da
fare non amano
il ragazzo poi vi spiego un ragazzo
molto bravo anno cosa fai ti spiego cosa
fa come vai lì e mi vengono a prendere
perchè gli ho detto come faccio da team
alpha no non ti preoccupare tt recupero
io a stai attento
giampaolo guarda io gli chiedo perdono
perché sono andati a prenderlo mio
cugino il mio fratello
cioè nel senso
tu hai visto invece che una limousine
nera con un uomo brizzolato in livrea ai
risultato è stato scappati di casa che
guidavano un bidone dell'umido detto mi
raccomando ragazzi subito quanti anni
rai posata perché ti chiami trentenni e
poi tre decenni sono 42 quando entrava
in pace stavo per dire che mai allenato
mia madre tra l'altro mi ha detto ma vai
da sola forse la stefy c he raggiunge
speriamo ecco perché mi ha detto ci
aggiunge anche la spugna e provarci
raggiungere anche la stefi ma dove 26 io
molto fuori dal centro
e oggi poi scherzando che pure detto beh
sa in realtà noi siamo facciamo del bene
per uccidiamo le persone come os x
grazie per il decollo che ragazzi cosa
sta succedendo chi è che sta portando al
mio
mettete in silenzioso il tempio telefono
delle cose per cui ero più convinta da
ragazzino erano sicuramente quei fili
della corrente che vanno quelle palle al
centro e che io ero convinta che fossero
le foche ball dei pokémon
spero di non essere l'unica ma credo di
no io pensavo fossero volto al bambù
realtà che sono i pokémon cioè lido di
catturare pene è tutta colpa vostro il
pokémon go il gioco allora che già ha
detto pokémon e colpa insieme che tu già
capisce che stiamo incominciando a ad
allontanarci no si hai ragione però qui
si sentono quei quattro anni di di
finanza no perché quando sono usciti
pokémon il primo io avrò avuto 12 anni e
io però arriviamo 16 ma un sedicenne
cioè ma chi se ne frega la tortura vive
pokémon
forse sì hai ragione solo che io ero già
un po punk a bestia un po troppo farti
notare da quelli ancora più grande bravo
adesso invece che cosa facciamo andiamo
fuori dalle scuole nella dei licei nella
speranza che fuori dalle università
court bosino perilli per il per il
metallo è presente spire io ho un
fratello
siccome sono la maggiore gli raccontavo
sempre che era stato adottato anche se
non era vero un giorno lui risposta mi
disse che c'era uno squalo che poteva
uscire fuori dal padre in qualsiasi
momento e non andare più in bagno
dovettero anche portarmi all'ospedale
perché ho paura che dal gesto potesse
uscire un enorme squalo e armi non so
cosa io non a questi livelli che non
valuto in bagno però ancora un po il
terrore che qualcosa esca e mi è
successa una cosa a un certo punto mi
sono alzato finito guarda trovata c'era
una cimice che equivale più o meno lo
squalo più bassi quindi tu sei stata
tutto il tempo con una cimice sottovuoto
che poteva anche sono poggiarsi sulla
camera che vuoi essere delicato sulla
gamba si sto cercando comunque di
mantenerlo friendly perché sei venuto
adesso perché parlava di adozione voi mi
avete fatto credere io all'altro giorno
io così stato adottato pezzi di
[Musica]
[Risate]
non c'è niente di te in merito quello
simpatico bello infatti ed è buono e
generoso fatto io sono la matrigna
cattiva
a me hanno sempre detto per esempio da
quando ero piccolo che io ero un
bastardo capriate giorno certo concepito
prima del matrimonio quindi
automaticamente uno snow e tu hai
creduto e quindi non ricordo che quando
ero piccola lista una fase che avremo 90
avere la febbre in modo da non andare a
scuola il giorno dopo primarie loro
visse dina dire queste cose perché se
fosse va fatto un angelo mentre io dice
cosa mi avrebbe fatto avere il desiderio
quindi sarei stato a mare da lì ho
sempre avuto paura di dire determinate
cose ad esempio quando mirato con una
persona facile tipo ammazzati voglio che
tu muoia o queste cose qui insomma
ciao jenny savastano grazie mille cioè
grazie a domani nel casinò testi spero
che tu muoia che vive che cos'è molto
noti gli angeli assassinato mali ex gli
angeli dovessero avverare tutti i
desideri che ho detto a voce alta dovrei
avere la metà dei miei nemici al
cimitero e soprattutto vivere in una
villa nel colosseo
non so che è poi si idem forse sarei
molto più alta molto più magra è molto
più alta ma sembrerebbe che in realtà è
tutto fitto infatti sono altre mani
amici da certe prova ok era una ciglia
con mascara beh tipi con un commento di
una cesta per formare tesoro era una
sfida che cosa cara maps
allora io ho due esperienze una
è di una mia amica quando partiva la
ruota della fortuna e tutti applaudivano
e di ciano ecco a voi
iva zanicchi lei pensava che i fagiani
chi fossero le persone del pubblico che
applaudiva sono chiamate così come un
popolo islamico
la cosa ma pensavo io che il banco ma
forse è una banca che fosse impazzire
appunto banco ma che ti desse soldi
gratis meravigliose a queste sono
stupendi in quanto matt che ti regala
soldi che bello perché passaggio
nell'area bancomat che regala soldi nel
giorno mi chiamo io ho dato un video che
i cammelli vivessero sono vaste e
rovinarsi è un'altra e disse anche non
mia madre proprio convinta ma come mi
cadono addosso quindi le donne da venere
i cammelli vengono da marte
io da piccola credevo che fa i boschi
insieme di alberi piazzati livelli
simmetrici paura è proprio quella io
credevo che nascessero perfetti così
detto silvia ma guarda te li piantano
così ha detto la piccola ma in realtà
tra lui fa davvero ma aspetta tu parli
di quelli che chiaramente sono stati
piantati da qualcuno ma gli alberi non
sono almeno tanto alti poi non hai la
nota soprattutto aspetta da che
prospettiva su altissimi dalla mia non
volevo prendere in giro tutti quanta
verso le basse del mondo alla fine il
solamente un numero a tutti quelli che
pensano che i boschi per noi ragazze
forse un po giro abilitate 82 silvia dei
trentenni dell'ade prendere alla stessa
questa che è una punta mentre secondo me
sono stato al terapista le chiedono di
andare tu oggi spese che silvia di
trentenni il trio di ragazze le
assomigliava e sequestro di persona
ragazzi la mamma non ho mandato un
messaggio per sapere che cosa sta
facendo questa mia amica alla stazione
da tre ore quando ero piccina ero o
super ossessionata da sailor moon che
quando cioè le più grandi se ovviamente
mi prendevano sempre in giro e una cosa
che mi è rimasta impressa di quello che
mi dicevano che segue moon in realtà si
chiamava allora nun e basta perché la
sigla diceva sei nord non si è mai che
insieme a iva zanicchi prendono come la
medaglia per incapacità di comprendere
le canzoni che in realtà è lord esatto
sailor moon non ci sto non andiamo a
prendere in giro una persona no persino
room ragazzo soprattutto se sei sorella
più grande
io non ci credo che sei sano se prendi
in giro per sailor moon cordi tuoi
cartoni erano david gnomo
noi vi diamo david amico mio era un uomo
col cappello rosso è enorme ma andava in
giro i boschi e penale non puoi
permetterti di prendere in giro tua
sorella che guarda sailor moon si è
cresciuta con davide non è permesso
facciamogli il mood io quando ero
piccola prendevo tutti i miei pupazzi e
quando andavo a letto li mettevo vicino
a me sotto le coperte con la faccia
rivolta verso l'esterno un demente
perché se non lavora che sul suo calcio
e lo facevo ogni sera e se non dovevo
farlo perché mi annoiava mi sentivo
incolto e pensavo che morissero di
fredde che potevano morire di freddo e
poi ce l'avessero con di continuità per
tantissimo tempo ho fatto questa cosa
dottor a me ne pento perché non avevo
spazio nemmeno per muovervi invasione il
modo di come i trattati amici ti prego
non offrire la mia giacca o di pregando
per dire mia maglietta per questa mia
nonna in buona fede però in modo
traumatico da piccolo mi diceva che se
mangiamo due banane o più sarei morta
in più per convincermi a non prendere le
cose da tecnici ma che se avessi preso
qualcosa terra avrei preso il tetano in
cui avverte tutto il ciclo a 10 anni
sempre il mio nonno ha detto che se
facevo la doccia con l'acqua calda mi
sei venuto l'emorragia e sarei morto che
parla veramente in modo migliore e
proprio per lui ha più senso però non
cupo non prenderlo che sennò l'uomo nero
non prenderlo perché per come mori quali
sapessero le vecchie questa è
l'indicazione italiana perché muore in
carica menzionati da 36 anni è
intrattenuto a te che ad ora nella tua
mente mondiale dei miei genitori perché
volevo vogliamo di non farmi andare via
mi minacciarono dicendo che non me ne
fossi andato che si sarebbero levate la
fede e le io non capendo come li masi
aveva ladri mistero anche se si fosse ma
nella fede
è scomparsa nel nulla dalla che magari
più tutti boscoletto maternità la tua io
non avrei dormito mai più nella computer
o tre ragazze che mi tolgo la fede to
scomparirà dal mondo e dalla memoria di
tutti ma sai quante persone dovrebbero
scomparire madre santa terribile che
seguire tipo la norma muori già fatte di
via perché se non muori mori è sempre
quello
ragazzi siamo arrivati alla fine questo
video si vede ti ringrazio ancora di
cuore per per esserti così prestata
questa cosa ti ringrazio anche per aver
rischiato la vita vita
ringraziate per avermi fatto vivere
questo brivido di essere superata da due
scappati di casa
fate essermi fidata averci creduto fino
in fondo perché mi sono divertita molto
il perché è il ritorno infatti non è
l'andazzo e ricorderò sempre come sempre
l'invito a farmi sapere qua sotto quali
sono state le vostre esperienze legate
al tema ma soprattutto quali sono altri
temi che mi piacerebbe vedere
all'interno di questa rubrica se avete i
suggerimenti visto che io spero
personalità e zero inventiva in questo
momento storico nella mia vita
vi invito a iscrivervi al mio canale
hulk analisi il via i trentenni che mi
metto tutto quanto in infobox e che dire
ciao ciao grazie ciao voi alla prossima
settimana a mestre